mais on va aller faire un tour aux états
unis on le voyait il ya près de 124
mille cas confirmés plus de 2200 morts
dans l'état de new york est l'épicentre
de l'épidémie
eh bien on compte plus de 50 mika près
de 900 décès je retrouve sur place un
médecin qui soigne des patients depuis
des jours docteur julien kavanagh
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
ce matin je sais que les journées sont
très très remplis pour vous très
difficile aussi le nombre de morts a
doublé en deux jours dans l'état de new
york
racontez nous comment ça se passe dans
les hôpitaux écoutez on fait face à une
véritable situation de catastrophe
sanitaire ici ici à new york
le nombre de cas a augmenté de façon
absolument exponentielle nous sommes
trois hôpitaux partenaires dont un
hôpital des tas qui ait le dantec mais
les corses center on a les deux cas il
ya deux semaines on est maintenant à
plus de 500 et je parle des patients
hospitalisés
donc c'est un afflux de patients fumant
sans précédent à quoi ressemblent vos
journées d'acteurs kavanagh alors mes
journées si vous voulez elle ressemble à
d'abord un effort de redéploiement de
l'ensemble des médecins de l'hôpital qui
doivent se mobiliser pour aider les
services d'urgence les services de
médecine les services de réanimation les
uns après les autres les spécialistes
qui ne sommes pas des médecins d'urgence
les médecins de médecine interne doivent
aller et des soins d'urgence soit en
unités qu'on appelle des unités qu'ovide
si vous voulez qu'ils sont des unités
qui sont scellées avec des films
plastiques
il faut s'habiller entièrement avec tous
les équipements de protection etc ce qui
est très difficile de travailler dans
ces conditions là si vous voulez parce
que vous avez du mal à respirer
quand vous avez des lunettes de
protection c'est un métier de contact
avec les avec les malades et vous perdez
partie d'une partie de ça donc c'est des
journées qui étaient des nuits et sont
difficiles vous mais vous ne relègue
présentement vous travaillez dans les
urgences pour soigner des gens qui sont
atteints de lakovic 19
vous parlez d'une catastrophe sanitaire
est ce que vous craignez un débordement
des hôpitaux comme ça qu'on assiste en
italie présentement on fait tout pour ne
pas en arriver là mais je suis pas en
mesure de vous promettre qu'on va qu'on
va y arriver
la stratégie aujourd'hui c'est de
séparer les malades que 8,19 des autres
malades pour pas avoir de contamination
hospitalière le downtime à l'écocentre
où je travaille à partir de demain sera
exclusivement à l'hôpital covin 19 on
attend un navire de la navy américaine
pour prendre en charge les malades qui
n'ont pas le commis de 19 et au centre
de conventions j'habite on va offrir
aussi un héros mittal de campagne pour
essayer de retirer tous les malades non
qu'ovide 19 qui vont continuer à avoir
des problèmes de santé des infarctus du
myocarde des accidents vasculaires
cérébraux continuer à soigner ses
malades en attente car renault c'est
dans la dernière heure à mettre l'état
en quarantaine est ce que les mesures
qui sont en place présentement vous
semble suffisante
écoutez ça c'est aux autorités publiques
de santé de le décider de le voir le
sentiment qu'on a un peu en marchant
dans les rues de new york c'est qu'il ya
encore un peu de monde
on sait tous que c'est difficile d'être
aux fines et à domicile mais les parts
qu'il y avait encore beaucoup de monde
dans dans les parcs cette semaine quant
au gouverneur veut essayer de sévir il
faut vraiment qu'on réussisse ce
confinement
c'est c'est crucial pour limiter la
propagation de l'infection bien plus on
voit à quel point ça accélère rapidement
ça a pris presque un mois à avoir 1000
décès dans l'état de new york et deux
jours pour en arriver à plus de 2000
alors c'est exponentiel là présentement
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète le plus
ce qui m'inquiète le plus je pense que
d'avoir des places pour les malades on
va on va tout faire pour pouvoir
accueillir tous les tous les malades on
va avoir un problème de matériel c'est à
dire d'avoir tous les équipements dont
on a besoin au quotidien pour soigner
pour soigner les malades c'est à dire
des l'idée sera électrique des
équipements de protection personnelle
pour les pour les soignants mais aussi
les ventilateurs pour pouvoir mettre
sous respiration artificielle des
passions qui le nécessitent
et puis c'est aussi des bras c'est à
dire avoir suffisamment de personnes
formées des infirmières des médecins
pour prendre en charge en charge des
malades et à ce titre le gouverneur est
en train de suspendre sa forme de
régulation qui comme au canada sont
extrêmement strictes pour savoir qui est
en mesure de travailler qui est en
mesure de voir des malades de façon à ce
qu'on puisse prendre dans nos rangs des
médecins étrangers d'autres spécialistes
d'autres cliniciens etc et et nous au
canada en fait on est un peu derrière
vous pour l'instant on assistait pas une
augmentation ses fulgurantes des cas
mais ça pourrait venir d'acteurs
kavanagh qu'est ce que vous pourriez
dire aux canadiens terminent un mois je
vraiment je voudrais je suis pas
québécois mais je suis un ami du peuple
québécois un ami du peuple canadien et
je voudrais vraiment vous dire faites
tous dès aujourd'hui pour vous confiné
c'est la stratégie qui offre la
meilleure chance si vous réussissez
votre confinement la progression de
l'épidémie au canada peut s'arrêter et
dans quelques semaines vous pourrez re
sortir de votre de votre profil mans ne
pas laisser votre système de santé ce
déborder donc c'est vraiment un rendez
vous historique je crois pour le le
canada et le et le québec et je vous
conjure de ne pas manquer ce rendez vous
message entendu docteur julien cabana
merci d'avoir été avec nos filles bien
sûr on vous souhaite la meilleure
également aux américains merci beaucoup
c'est moi qui vous remercie et bonne
journée